[Musique]
froid s'est déchiré blanc ou transparent
le papier le terrain de jeu de charih
goyenetxe différentes textures qui
interpelle le toucher et le regard une
matière subtile et délicate
c'est qui m'a plu c'est les côtés et que
je pouvais déchiré et qui très vite et
je pouvais faire des contre acheter et
avec les chambrer et les papiers et donc
que c'était la matière qui s'y prêtait
l'aimiez et asselah
mais les blancs et les chambres et il
n'ya pas d'ennemis et qu'elle est
blanche professeur d'arts plastiques à
magny les hameaux depuis 20 ans jarry
goyenetxe est mise à l'honneur dans une
exposition
l'occasion de découvrir ses oeuvres
inspirées par la nature et l'espace mais
aussi par ses origines basques
je me suis intéressé par la lune et est
donc je vais beaucoup des tableaux où il
y à la rondeur est inspiré de la lune et
après on m'avait dit au pays basque et
primat des lunettes
en basque et la gnac et ça veut dire
lumière des morts c'est cela qui me
plaît c'est un bien c'est entrer les
réelles et pas réel
l'imagination un univers où se mêlent la
lumière et des ombres différent à chaque
heure pour y plonger
des visites sont organisées jusqu'à
dimanche 21 mai en présence de l'artiste